ketchup and mustard and stranger things
and bloopers galore I have seen into the
future and I have seen that today is a
new day a day full of girls
yeah the show shared so many funny
outtakes on their Instagram account it
was all in honor of stranger things day
November 6 ay ka the day will buyers
went missing and honestly it's hard to
choose a favorite moment I know it's
hard but it might be David Harbour and
his grandma did your grandma I don't
know your mom called she needs your home
right away is everything okay
no I don't think so it's your grandma
it's your grandma yeah the show also
gave us a bloopers from season two which
included some pretty epic dance moves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and yeah we also got these gifts from
season one
sorry I was just improving but that's
not all they graced us with great guys
we also got the name of the first
episode from season four chapter 1 the
Hellfire Club now we've also talked to
the cast a bit about season 4 here's
what they've spilled
[Music]
it's all gonna be okay I mean I hope
you're entertained I hope you're moved
and I hope you just loved it like I did
we're really sorry that you're so sad
but I got regular I'm happy that you're
safe yeah yeah we then we did a good job
actly please keep the door open I think
I'm at the kurios
two doors Nigel and you enjoy the show
thank you so much see you in season four
all right if we alright guys that's it
for today for all the latest on stranger
things stick with all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krause and bye for
now
[Music]